[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland eurem täglichen truecrime
Podcast mein Name ist Mirko Kasimir und
ich bin Toni Heyer Mirko wir haben heute
mal wieder eine von diesen Geschichten
oder ja eine von diesen Geschichten ohne
Abschluss ein ungeklärter Mordfall und
ich weiß nicht wie es Dir geht Mirko
aber ich kann mir kaum etwas Schlimmeres
vorstellen als einen geliebten Menschen
durch ein Verbrechen zu verlieren ich
meine es ist eh schon schlimm ein
geliebten Menschen zu verlieren aber das
wissen ein geliebten Menschen durch ein
Verbrechen zu verlieren und immer daran
denken zu müssen dass der Täter noch
frei herum läuft das muss das Schlimmste
überhaupt sein dass man ihm im
Supermarkt begegnen könnte ohne zu
wissen dass er es ist ohne zu wissen
warum warum er es getan hat oder ob er
es bereut oder einfach sein Leben lebt
als sei nichts gewesen ja da hast du
recht das ist eine absolut furchtbare
Vorstellung ich meine auch wenn der
Mörder gefasst und verurteilt wird macht
es die Dinge nicht wieder ungeschehen
oder in irgendeiner Weise wieder gut
aber man erfährt zumindest etwas über
das wie und wo und eventuell auch über
das Warum auch wenn die Antworten darauf
wahrscheinlich unerträglich sind ja und
das ist wichtig für die Angehörigen dass
das Recht sich durchsetzt dass die Tat
Konsequenzen hat und das dem Täter nicht
erlaubt wird einfach sein Leben
vorzusetzen nachdem er ein anderes
zerstört hat mehr besonders wichtig
natürlich für die Angehörigen aber auch
für die Gesellschaft im Allgemeinen dass
eine Art Gerechtigkeit herrscht
die Aufklärungsquote für erkannte Morde
liegt in Deutschland übrigens bei ca
95%. es ist also sehr selten dass jemand
mit so etwas durchkommt zum Glück aber
es kommt vor und eine solche Geschichte
erzählen wir heute die Geschichte von
Anja die nur 16 Jahre alt wurde und
ihrer Mutter die bis heute mit der
Trauer und der Ungewissheit lebt Mirko
es ist der 4 september 1998 ein Freitag
Aschersleben feiert in der Kleinstadt in
Sachsen-Anhalt gelegen am Rande des Harz
begeht man an diesem Wochenende das
große Stadtfest höhepunkt soll das
Feuerwerk am folgenden Samstagabend sein
in der Diskothek Manege feiern etwa 800
Jugendliche ihre eigene Party tanzen und
flirten die Welt da draußen vergessen
eine von ihnen ist die 16-jährige Anja
längnig gegen 21 Uhr verlässt Anja die
Wohnung ihre Eltern in einem
DDR-Plattenbau und macht sich mit zwei
Freundinnen auf den Weg zur manische
sie ist eine fröhliche junge Frau die
sich auf eine Nacht voller Spaß und
Ausgelassenheit freut niemand Art wie
diese Nacht stattdessen ausgehen wird
oder weiß der Täter bereits dass er zum
Mörder werden wird ist der einer der
Jugendlichen die in der Manege in den
Samstag hinein feiern eigentlich will
Anja bei einer Freundin übernachten doch
zwischen 1:45 Uhr und 2 Uhr macht sie
sich letztendlich doch allein auf den
Heimweg von der Disco es sind etwa 2 km
bis zu Ihrem zu Hause einem
viergeschossigen Plattenbau in der Jude
dresdenkstraße 1
gut eine halbe Stunde braucht sie
normalerweise für den Weg der kürzeste
Weg nach Hause führt vorbei am großen
Friedhof der Stadt
also jetzt mal abgesehen von
irgendwelchen Horrorszenarien wie
Gespenstern oder Zombies so ein Friedhof
nachts ist halt keine gute Idee weil es
halt nicht beleuchtet bzw nur sehr sehr
schlecht
wir wissen nicht ob Anja sich auch
solche Gedanken gemacht hat jedenfalls
nimmt sie in dieser Nacht lieber den
etwas längeren belebteren und
vermeintlich sichereren Weg über die
Bahnhofstraße die Herrenbreite und die
küstener Straße der Heimweg kann später
anhand mehrere Zeugenaussagen genau
rekonstruiert werden die meisten Zeugen
sehen sie vom Auto aus es sind
Jugendliche die zu dieser späten Stunde
noch zu einer Disco unterwegs sind oder
sich schnell an einer Tankstelle etwas
kaufen wollen zuletzt wird sie gegen
2:20 Uhr Leben gesehen Anja ist da nur
noch etwa 300 Meter von zu Hause
entfernt kurz darauf wird sie
angegriffen zweimal sticht der Täter von
hinten auf Anja ein die junge Frau wehrt
sich aber sie hat keine Chance die
Stiche treffen Niere Zwerchfell und
andere innere Organe dann lässt der
Täter von ihr ab und flieht
Anja ist da noch am leben sie ist schwer
verletzt doch sie kämpft
sie schleppt sich die ganzen 300 Meter
bis nach Hause bis zum Eingang des
Plattenbaus sie schafft es die Schlüssel
aus der Hosentasche zu ziehen und
versucht die Tür zu öffnen aber in dem
Moment verlassen Sie die Kräfte
das ist so unvorstellbar schon den
Gedanken wenn man versucht sich das
bildlich vorzustellen das finde ich kaum
auszuhalten überleg mal ihre Eltern und
ihre jüngere Schwester die schlafen oben
in ihren Betten in der Wohnung und Anja
stirbt unten auf der Türschwelle ihres
Hauses in diesem Moment es ist 3:45 Uhr
als eine zeitungszustellerin den
leblosen Körper von Anja längnig findet
der Notarzt kannst du diesem Zeitpunkt
nur noch den Tod feststellen
Anjas Familie erfährt erst Stunden
später gegen 7 Uhr morgens was passiert
ist jeder Mord ist schrecklich keine
Frage und das Leid der Opfer und der
Hinterbliebenen kaum zu fassen was sie
durchmachen aber ehrlich ich komme in
diesem Fall nicht darüber hinweg das
Anja vor ihrem Haus liegt nur wenige
Meter von ihren Liebsten entfernt und
auf dieser Türschwelle stirbt Anjas
Mutter quälen diese Gedanken seit
beinahe 25 Jahren Tag für Tag
in einem Interview mit Bild sagt sie man
kann es nicht vergessen man sagt sich
immer jetzt wäre sie in dem Alter wo sie
Kinder gehabt hätte man wäre vielleicht
Oma aber es sollte nicht sein
die ganze Stadt steht nach dem Mord
unter Schock Aschersleben ist ganz
sicher kein sorgenfreier Ort wie überall
in den neuen Bundesländern hat die Wände
zu starken Verwerfungen geführt doch mit
so etwas hat man hier nicht gerechnet
sowas passiert doch eher in der großen
Stadt am Abend nach der Tat soll
eigentlich ein großes Feuerwerk den
Höhepunkt und Abschluss der Stadtfestes
bilden doch niemandem ist mehr nach
Feiern zumute das Feuerwerk wird
abgesagt stattdessen liegen viele
Menschen Blumen und Plüschtiere vor dem
Haus der Familie ab und stellen Kerzen
auf zwei Fragen beschäftigen die
Menschen warum und wer und diese Fragen
beschäftigen natürlich auch die Polizei
sie bildet eine 16-köpfige
Ermittlergruppe alle Spuren werden
gesichert und ausgewertet Zeugen werden
gesucht und befragt und bald zeichnet
sich ein Bild ab
ein Raub oder Sexualdelikt kann schnell
ausgeschlossen werden
die Ermittler konzentrieren sich nun auf
eine Beziehungstat
drei Wochen vor dem Mord hat sich Anja
von ihrem 18-Jährigen Freund getrennt
könnte das Motiv Eifersucht sein Zeugen
sagen aus dass Anja sich in der Tatnacht
in der Diskothek mit ihrem Ex-Freund
gestritten hat Anja Sex ist in dieser
Nacht mit einem gleichaltrigen Freund
unterwegs später beobachten Mitarbeiter
eines burger-restaurants in
unmittelbarer Nähe des Tatortes auf dem
Parkplatz einen roten Kleinwagen mit
zwei Personen ein Wagen wie ihn auch
Anjas Ex-Freund fährt die beiden jungen
Männer werden festgenommen es gibt
Indizien die gegen sie sprechen aber
handfeste Beweise fehlen die Tatwaffe
zum Beispiel wurde bis heute nicht
gefunden
die Gerichtsmedizin geht von einem
Hirschfänger aus einem Messer mit einer
etwa 20 cm langen feststehenden Klinge
vielleicht hätte man daran Spuren finden
können die den oder die Täter überführen
aber ohne derartige Beweise müssen die
beiden jungen Männer bald wieder
freigelassen werden
Anjas Ex-Freund wird nicht angeklagt es
ist zum verzweifeln alle Spuren alle
Hinweise laufen ins Leere immer wieder
bitten Polizei und die Familie von Anja
um Mithilfe hoffen dass sich weitere
Zeugen melden vielleicht Mitesser
vielleicht sogar der Täter selbst kann
er mit seiner Tat leben kann er
Einschlafen mit dem Wissen was er getan
hat oder kommt der eines Tages an einem
Punkt wo er selbst Frieden will und sein
Verbrechen gesteht
[Musik]
es wird still um den Mord an ein Jahr
trotz aller Bemühungen der Mutter und
der Polizei der Fall Anja längnig wird
zum Cold Case und dann am 5 september
2014 auf den Tag genau 16 Jahre nach dem
Mord finden Spaziergänger ein Holzkreuz
genau an der Stelle an der Anja starb
auf dem Kreuz stehen Anjas Name ihr
Geburtsdatum und der Tag ihres Todes
anja wurde 16 Jahre alt 16 Jahre später
taucht das Kreuz auf
markiert es den Tag an dem Anja genauso
lange tot ist wie sie lebendig war die
Ermittlungen geraten wieder in Bewegung
schnell wird klar dass das Kreuz weder
von Angehörigen noch von Freunden
aufgestellt wurde aber von wem dann
der Verdacht liegt nahe dass es ein
Mitwisser war dessen gewissen ihn seit
16 Jahren plagt der versucht es auf
diese Weise zu beruhigen aber aus
welchem Grund auch immer nicht den Mut
findet zur Polizei zu gehen oder ist es
gar der Täter selbst glaubt er etwas
wiedergutmachen zu können indem er die
Erinnerung an Anja aufrechterhält sorry
aber wenn er das glaubt ist er nicht nur
ein Verbrecher sondern auch dumm er
sollte wissen dass Anja nie vergessen
wird nicht von ihrer Familie nicht von
ihren Freunden und auch nicht von der
Polizei den mord verjährt nicht und
abgeschlossen ist ein solcher Fall erst
wenn der Täter endlich gefasst wird
die einzige Möglichkeit Anja und den
Hinterbliebenen wenigstens ein bisschen
dabei zu helfen ihren Frieden zu finden
ist sich der Polizei zu stellen und zu
gestehen
mordverjährt nicht und Anjas Mutter gibt
die Hoffnung nicht auf dass der Fall
eines Tages gelöst wird immer wieder
wendet sie sich an die Öffentlichkeit
ruft Zeugen auf sich zu melden und
appelliert an den oder die Täter sich
endlich zu stellen aber es gibt Leute
die das nicht verstehen können bekannte
raten ihr doch endlich abzuschließen es
seien zu lassen und nicht immer wieder
alles aufzuwühlen
ich glaube nicht dass irgendjemand sich
anmaßen sollte ihr einen Rat zu geben
und ich selbst kann auch nur ansatzweise
mir vorstellen was sie erleben muss ich
meine das ist ihre Tochter ihr Baby ihr
kann niemand sagen was sie tun sollte
und nicht wie sie mit der Trauer umgeht
ich versuche wie immer trotzdem ein
positiven Abschluss für so eine
Geschichte zu finden okay da machst du
mich jetzt ganz schön neugierig okay
erwarte nicht zu viel es ist wirklich
nur ein winzig kleines Glühwürmchen im
stockfinsterer Nacht sozusagen aber wir
haben uns doch zur Vorbereitung dieser
Episode diese zweiteilige Doku Cold Case
Anja langnick angeschaut ne ja stimmt
und darin gab es eine Szene die mich
wirklich sehr sehr berührt hat der
Reporter Thilo Schulte Sex sitzt bei
Anjas Mutter im Wohnzimmer die beiden
haben schon eine Weile gesprochen sie
hat viel geweint und das waren wirklich
trauriges bewegendes Gespräch und dann
erzählt sie dass sie vor dem Interview
eine Videokassette aus dem Keller geholt
hat diese sich viele Jahre nicht getraut
hat anzuschauen ja ich weiß was du
meinst ja das Video wurde 1996
aufgenommen zwei Jahre vor Anja tot auf
der Feier zu ihrer Jugendweihe man sieht
ein fröhliches aufgeregtes und
glückliches Mädchen an der Schwelle zum
Erwachsenwerden und sie lacht
unbeschwert wie jemand der ein ganzes
Leben und unendliche Möglichkeiten vor
sich hat und die Mutter sagte zum
Reporter
wie es angemacht habe wir sind hier drin
gekommen
vor Freude jetzt dass ich sogar noch mal
sehe
diese Nummer in diesem Moment hat sie
nicht aus Trauer geweint sondern aus
Dankbarkeit dafür dass Anja da war
[Musik]
ja ja Glühwürmchen in stockfinster und
Nacht ich glaube das trifft wirklich
ganz gut aber immerhin ich finde das
zeigt halt auch so ein bisschen dass sie
in ihrer Trauer trotzdem ein klein
hoffnungsschwimmer gefunden hat um
ansatzweise ich glaube nicht dass der
Tod eines Kindes jemals
verkraftet werden kann kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen weil das ist dann ein
Fleisch und Blut das hast du auch als
Mutter das Baby ist in dir angewachsen
du hast es auf die Welt gebracht aber
dass sie zumindest ein winzig kleinen
Schritt in Richtung Akzeptanz gefunden
hat das finde ich so schön und ich
glaube das ist ganz wertvoll ja ich
glaube wir haben im Prinzip das
eigentlich ich glaube das Resümee dieser
dieser Geschichte ist ja immer dass man
wenn man die Eltern so in dieser Trauer
zurück lässt dass die dass man denen
wünscht dass sie irgendwann damit lernen
umzugehen weil die werden es nie
verkraften können das funktioniert
einfach nicht aber zumindest lernen
damit zu leben dass sie ihr Leben so es
geht weiter leben können das kann man
den Angehörigen den Eltern nur wünschen
das ist glaube ich so der wichtigste der
wichtigste Punkt und wenn natürlich
irgendwann der Mörder gefunden wird
ja dann wäre das sozusagen vielleicht
das kann man davon im sanohäppchen
Sprechen ich finde das jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen euphemistisch aber dann
wäre das natürlich vielleicht der Punkt
wo man dann den nächsten Schritt gehen
könnte um die ganze Sache zu verarbeiten
definitiv Mirko da stimme ich sie jetzt
zu 1000% zu ja und damit sind wir auch
schon wieder am Ende dieser Geschichte
die ja bis heute leider noch nicht
geklärt ist und auch nicht wirklich ein
richtiges Ende hat wir haben diese
Geschichte erzählt anhand der erwähnten
Doku Cold Case Anja langnick von Bild TV
sowie von Artikeln der Mitteldeutschen
Zeitung und der Volksstimme wir bedanken
uns ganz herzlich bei euch fürs zuhören
und freuen uns wenn ihr auch beim
nächsten Mal wieder dabei seid euer
Mirko und eure Toni Redaktion Stefan
Skript und Postproduktion weight Studios